oh
oh my word there is no voice there is no
voice they don't want to talk do it Doug
du can you just freestyle
it all right no no no no can you do it
can you do it live waiting for his lips
to move dug up that Bloody information
you want okay we're just about to choose
an option don't forget we're an PG
that's what it's all about so what
should they pick oh dster I really think
you're quite
cute Doug pretty cozy shelter oh yes oh
mag I
AG we knew you'd telling
[Music]
him
Johnny yes
now then just picture this extremely
annoying
voice
voice I'm looking for a young Ashen
haired woman see anyone like that did I
ever remember as if were yesterday as
soon as I woke I went to empty my bowels
my favorite part of the day defecating
in the sunrise downright
glorious no it's not allowed
she sounds quite sexy actually doesn't
she oh gods and her master's watch over
F this is
live and the words are very
small
put
[Applause]
and I love
you